all right one other rule that's going to
reportedly be tweaked and this is
another report from judy batista of nfl
media and look
i walk a fine line anytime i point this
out any reporter who works for nfl media
is working for the nfl there's an
inherent conflict of interest there and
a pattern develops every time they're
going to have one of these meetings
somebody from the competition committee
or the league office tells judy batista
what is expected to happen and it feels
official because it's coming from nfl
media now
i don't know who the person is that's
supplying the information is it somebody
who's trying to tip the scale one way or
the other is it somebody who has an
opinion that is emanating from the
existence of the report is it a trial
balloon that's being put out there by
someone to see how people react to it we
never know that but the bottom line is
it feels official but we shouldn't
regard it as official it's not official
until they do it and this potential
change relates to the replay review
expansion to encompass past interference
there's a chance that the rules will be
revised to
make pass interference reviewable only
through the coaches challenge not
through the automatic system where
there's replay review available without
a coach's challenge final two minutes of
either half over time after a touchdown
or after a turnover
um
the idea is as explained in the various
tweets that were posted by judy batista
that there would be
greater consistency in the standard if
the league office isn't involved in the
automatic review it look it makes no
sense
because the coaches aren't reviewing the
play the coaches are just initiating the
process
and for the automatic replay review it
doesn't take much to initiate the
process
see i
i i think what they're trying to do is
reduce the number of times that you
would feel compelled to initiate the
process because the way it's supposed to
work to overturn the ruling on the field
through the replay review process
there should be clear and obvious
evidence that the ruling on the field
was incorrect to initiate the process
the way it's always been
it has to be clear and obvious that the
ruling on the field was correct if it's
not clear and obvious that it was
correct then you fall into that gulf
where you try to figure out whether or
not there's clear and obvious evidence
that was incorrect see here's what
becomes a problem with past interference
it's going to be very easy to hit the
button and say we need to give this a
second look because
there'll be plenty of cases of hand
fighting and jostling and incidental
contact where it's not going to be clear
and obvious that there wasn't pass
interference and so if that's the case
you don't want to have a full-blown
replay review every time there's a score
every time there's a pass thrown in the
final two minutes every time there's a
turnover
and then you take the time you do it you
say no that it wasn't enough to overturn
it that's the problem so
the standard
threshold
for triggering replay review it's going
to get tripped a lot as it relates to
past interference and you know what i
haven't thought of that one either
sometimes it makes sense to sound this
stuff out even if i'm doing it somewhat
clumsily and hey does the fact that i
admit it make it any better probably not
but you could maybe sense the gears
turning in my brain here i see what
they're getting at it's not a matter of
having a consistent standard it's a
matter of not wanting to apply the
standard that applies to
when
the replay official says we need to have
a full-blown replay review so i think i
understand what they're trying to do
here
it just it it creates a potential mess
if you don't have any red flags left
because you get two unless you're right
on the first two then you get a third
um and you have to have a timeout left
or you can't use the red flag anyway
because you lose a timeout as the
punishment for being wrong they maybe
need to relook
at the challenge system if they're gonna
do this because
there's a chance that you could have an
egregious call like the one we saw in
ram saints in the nfc championship game
and you don't have a red flag or you
don't have a timeout at your disposal to
correct what would be a horrible call
that needs to be rectified immediately
so look this is not i think the problem
is
the competition committee tried to drag
its feet from january into march and not
propose any meaningful change and they
got to the league meeting they realized
oh crap
they really want this to change and they
threw something together quickly and
they really didn't think it all through
and frankly i hadn't thought it through
from the perspective of how easy it is
and how little it will take to trigger a
full-blown replay review
of potential pass interference
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports